we regularly in chemistry we use thermos
flasks you know like a like you keep for
coffee or soup and we use them as
glasses to keep things cold and what we
thought we'd show you today is how I
some chemistry one of the elements is
used to make a thermos flask so Neal is
taking one apart what we can see here is
the inside of the thermos flask so this
is just a glass envelope which we
connect to a pump and we suck out all
the atmosphere to make a vacuum inside
and we also silver the inside of that
glass just so that we can see make it
like nice and pretty
such that the any heat that is in there
is bounce back in reflected back in okay
so we thought we'd show you how we seal
with some glass because that's pretty
cool chemistry of silver so I'm the
starting material for this is am a
favorite silver nitrate what we need to
do first is to make a salt make a salt
solution and we've done that by
dissolving silver nitrate in some
deionized water the next step for this
reaction is really to make that silver a
little bit more reactive and we're going
to do that by reacting it with ammonia
solution as we add the ammonia we should
see a chemical change really quickly
they had a few more drops you can see
these big clouds of a new product coming
this is actually silver hydroxide and
it's the silver reacting with hydroxide
within the aqueous ammonia solution that
we're putting in which makes this new
product or this really nice brownie sort
of precipitate so if we give that a bit
of a mix we can make that complete
reaction it's quite nice in itself and
it's a really nice chemical reaction to
watch but it's not really what we need
okay
so what we need to do now is react that
further by adding more ammonia so the
ammonia the nh3 displaces the hydroxide
it kicks it out a bit like a competition
reaction these are very delicate
equilibrium reaction so they go very
very quickly
we've reacted all of that silver
hydroxide and made the silver diamine
compound that we need now all we need to
do is put it into the flask that we want
to make silver and add something that'll
reduce it and we're going to use a sugar
solution and we thought we'd silver this
class today so it's a nice round bottom
flask we can pour the silver in solution
in this is a solution of sugar similar
to the sugar that we put in a cup of tea
or coffee that we've made with deionized
water and we're now going to add it to
the silver ring solution and now warm
the solution to about 70 degrees am I
going to do that using the water bath so
there's our sugar and our silver ring
solution and we'll leave that a few
moments and we'll come back and see what
happens
okay so we've been doing all sorts of
experiments in the lab today and it's
about an hour since we set up the silver
mirror in experiment so I think what we
ought to do now is go back and have a
look and see if it's worked and we're
just going to lift it up now out of the
bath and we can see almost
instantaneously that the solution itself
has gone all grey which tells me that
something's happened to the silver now
I'm going to rotate the flask and I
think you can see there's a really nice
mirror which has been formed on the
bottom of that flask so we've reduced
the silver from the salt the diamine
complex to silver zero or metallic
silver which is then precipitated and
covered the glass perfect mirror that
we've formed on the on that on the the
inside of this flask so now what we need
to do is we need to remove the rest of
the excess solution and wash it with
water which will then stabilise the
mirror so that we've mirrored the vessel
so we've washed it with water because
the byproducts in this reaction could
contain quite energetic salts of silver
and we don't want any energetic
reactions in a nice new flask Sam I even
made a mirror
yeah there we go
is Royal stigmas